Oh
over the years I've become impressed
with how much the oceans have changed
just in my lifetime I realized that
since the middle of the 20th century
more has changed perhaps than during all
preceding human history that we can see
the change other creatures may as well
grouper may live 50 years and recognize
that the ocean is not the same ocean
that they experience there's little fish
dolphins certainly makes recognize the
difference they can live to be 50 or 60
years old bowhead whales can be 200
years old orange roughy can be 200 years
old tuna maybe 25 or 30 years old anyway
during this time the ocean has changed
but they don't know why and they don't
know what to do about it we do know why
and we do know what to do about it but
it's taken us a while it's taken the
half a century to really understand that
the view of Earth from space to see that
how you look all around there is only
one place where we can actually have a
hope of going forward in time we can
reflect on a long and illustrious
history but what about the future what
about the kids 50 years from now who
will look back on us and say why didn't
you do something when you had a chance
and when you knew that ninety percent of
the fish had been taken out of the sea
of certain species the tunas the
swordfish the Sharks the big fish are
gone and yet you kept eating tuna you
kept eating swordfish what were you
thinking if we continue right now doing
what we've been doing there won't be
these large creatures 50 years from now
and the kids will say why didn't you do
something when you still had a chance
that's what has shaped much of what I do
have been doing what drives me now as
much as I love just exploring the ocean
studying plants seaweeds I love them
they're just infinitely fascinating to
dive into an ecosystem and be a part of
it in and try to understand how
how does it work just for its own sake
just for wanting to know to satisfy my
personal curiosity to add a little
fragment of knowledge to the great body
of knowledge that might lead to wisdom
for our species but now we're running
out of time I can't indulge myself as
much as I once did as a young explorers
and younger scientists I now and
compelled to share the news the ocean is
in trouble we're in trouble we have to
go flat out to do what we can to embrace
what remains of healthy ecosystems on
the land and in the sea I've been
working with the National Park Service
and with protected areas the whole
concept on the land for many years
through I you see on the international
union for the conservation of nature
with World Wildlife with the National
Geographic Conservation International
with any organization that will have me
basically to try to help inspire care
for the natural systems as if our lives
depend on them because they do they do
its life that generates oxygen it's
their living systems that drive the
water cycle protecting watersheds to
maintain the integrity of that which
keeps us alive for the ocean for years
I've been trying to do for the ocean
what has been done for the land starting
early in the 20th century not early
enough but protected areas on the land
national parks and wildlife reserves and
so on that we should think of as people
reserves because they restore our life
not just about other creatures in the
sea it's a relatively new concept
starting in the 70s in Australia in this
country with protected areas the Great
Barrier Reef a system of sanctuaries in
this country now around the world 4,500
or so marine protected areas but they're
mostly really small it amounts to a
fraction of one percent of the ocean so
when I had a call from Chris Anderson
from
technology entertainment design Ted in
the fall of 2008 saying that I'd been
awarded the TED Prize I could make a
wish had to be a big wish big enough to
change the world it was really easy to
think what it would be it would be to
try to win support for what I've been
trying to do with other organizations
and people my fellow scientists and
others who care for most of my life
let's try to inspire a network of public
to it's sort of ignite public support
for Hope spots protected areas around
the world doesn't matter really what you
call them a sanctuary a reserve whatever
it is different organizations have gone
by different names but it's time to have
an umbrella term something that will
will allow others to do their thing but
within a framework of working together
so hope spots mission blue to pull
together to get others engaged who
haven't typically been engaged pull on
the draw on the entertainer's to
celebrate using their talents people ask
what can I do I say hold up a mirror
what cannon can you do what are you good
at do you write until you sing you have
a way with numbers are you a politician
and with a kind of power at this moment
in history are you a teacher or your mom
or your dad or your kid I don't whatever
you are you have power the trick is
using that power part of the wish with
Ted said expeditions and again the
tedsters as they are known call
themselves and Chris Anderson pulled
together to have an expedition and we
worked with lindblad expeditions
National Geographic Lindblad ship the
endeavour to go to the Galapagos Islands
a place that is an iconic place that is
has lots of reason for hope good things
are happening there but they're also
concerns because fishing continues to
degrade the ocean surrounding the island
and degrade the chances that wildlife
have and people have to make this a
source of hope for the future so we had
the expedition there with a hundred
people from different areas of expertise
that even the scientists although were
scientific colleagues and no one another
and there were maybe 30 of us in this
mix of a hundred people who are experts
in our relative respective disciplines
but we hadn't been captured together in
a place for a piece of time where we had
a chance to really think in new ways
about this real problem of how do we
take care of the ocean and inspire the
public at large to and people with other
talents to pull together and that's what
is actually what actually did happen in
the mission blue expedition that has had
a magical effect on everybody who was
there to mobilize the powers that they
have and pull together in and to create
a new wave of understanding